let's talk a little bit about what
happened and what is happening in Las
Vegas the fact that the victims of the
Las Vegas shooting are running
fundraising campaigns to cover their
medical expenses tells us everything we
need to know about our depraved and
disgusting healthcare system later on in
the program today I'll interview a
professor of economics Gerald Friedman
because he has actually he's known for
having run the numbers on what a
medicare-for-all type proposal would
cost we're going to talk to him later
the fact that we even need to be
donating money to the victims of the Las
Vegas shooting to the victims of Harvey
and Irma and Maria the government has
enough cash for cabinet members to fly
around on charter planes and for the
president to bankrupt the Secret Service
for protecting him and funneling
millions of dollars into his golf
courses for everything from room rentals
to renting golf carts and whatever else
but the victims of the worst mass
shooting in American history are running
GoFundMe campaigns to try to pay for
their own health insurance what can we
even do right I mean it feels hopeless
and to some degree yeah we can donate a
little money here and there to the
victims but we can't fix everything and
I saw an interesting tweet from dezirian
Abbas kovitch who's a science writer I
wasn't familiar with her she tweeted the
GOP insists that the Vegas shooters gun
arsenal is a right but medical treatment
for his 500 plus survivors is merely a
privilege now she was criticized because
it's not it's not literally true some of
the weapons that the shooter had were
illegally possessed but that doesn't
change the broader reality which is that
too many Americans see the gun ownership
as something that is a right that
shouldn't be regulated and health care
as something that is equivalent to a new
car you might be able to buy the new car
you might not but that's just kind of
how things work in our society this is
not a sustainable path and I know there
are people who will say listen some
people will have health care and some
won't and it won't affect me because I'm
in the top one
and or the top 5% or 10 or 20% of our
country the impact of growing income and
wealth inequality will affect you
because it affects everybody it
increases crime
it increases strife it increases the
propensity to violence and I've been
getting emails from the audience asking
David is this ever going to change
without some kind of violence Jerry
Friedman today we'll be talking to him
about how single-payer is affordable
period but I don't think the right cares
about that they say that it's all a
matter of financing and fiscal
conservatism but that's not true because
if it were we could already have
Medicare for all it is about who
deserves healthcare that's the
underlying issue for many on the right
if you can't afford it you don't deserve
it and that is a fundamental
philosophical disagreement statistically
since we have hundreds of victims from
the Las Vegas shooting statistically
speaking there will probably be people
who end up bankrupt as a result of
having been shot by Stephen paddock
period how is it a moral country that
allows that and if you're a conservative
in Nevada you're in the front row to
this horror and you see the stockpile of
weapons and ammunition that Stephen
Patek had and you see people you know
maybe it's people in your community
maybe it's friends maybe it's even
family who have been victims of the
shooting and they are struggling just to
afford health care does that affect you
at all at least a little how can you see
that front and center and say hey this
is the system we have we don't need
health care for all and as I mentioned
yesterday you know if if it takes
something like this happening in your
backyard to change your mind are you
really that empathetic and I know some
people wrote to me and they said David
yesterday I told you that there was a
country music guitarist who said the
shooting changed my mind and I said
that's great it's great that it changed
his mind but it's disappointing that he
lacked the empathy to understand why the
gun laws needed to be changed and gun
safety regulation needs to be changed
without having been personally connect
that really is is concerning to me now
because I'm making an effort to turn the
show into a catalyst for action there is
a race in Nevada you can get involved
with and I guess it's sort of related to
the incident any opportunity to tell you
about races you can get involved in I
will take rent Republican Senatorial
incumbent Dean Heller I've told you
about Dean Heller he's the guy who after
getting a call from casino owners Steve
Wynn and Sheldon Adelson in Nevada
changed his position on Trump care 3.0
and supported it to repeal the
Affordable Care Act he has a Democratic
challenger Democratic congresswoman
Jackie Rosen is challenging Dean Haller
in Nevada Heller is horrible and
fortunately is suffering a little bit
because of those hiccups around the
entire Trump Care 3.0 thing Jackie Rosen
supports affordable health care for
every American she supports properly
funding public schools supports
protecting Social Security and Medicare
supports renewable energy net neutrality
and daca thirteen months until that
election in November of 2018 get
involved okay I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show we'll take a break and be back
right after this movement watches
sponsoring today's program love having
movement watches as a sponsor I have a
movement watch and I wear it all the
time people love it might at my
dentist's office well you might be
wondering why might the dentist so much
that's a topic for a different day but
at my dentist's office every time I go
and sign in I get a question about
that's a really good watch where did you
get that and I got it online and that's
sort of the great thing about the
movement watch business model which is
by selling directly online to over a
hundred and sixty countries by the way
movement watches cuts out the middleman
so instead of paying four or five
hundred dollars or more for this caliber
and this well-designed
of a watch the watches start at just
ninety five dollars and not only is this
a company that has decided to sell only
online they're also similar to the david
pakman show and that they crowdfunded to
really launch the business initially and
it is a really really cool set of
watches and sunglasses which are also
available through movement
and you can save 15% if you go to MVM
t.com slash Pakman if you go to nvm
t.com slash Pakman you'll save 15% off
of your watch you will get free shipping
you'll also get free returns
MVM t.com slash pakman join the movement